former Fox News employees are demanding
to be released immediately from
agreements not to discuss section
settlement settlement of their sexual
harassment claims gretchen carlson
and julie rogue insky are among six
former employees reportedly pushing to
share their stories publicly the signed
non-disclosure agreements also known as
NDA's often trade silence for money CBS
this morning national correspondent
Jericka Duncan spoke with Carlson and
Ragan Ski Jerrica what they tell you
well it really comes down to this they
say they don't want to be forced into
silence any longer NBC News released
former employees from their NDA's just
last week which inspired the push at Fox
well in the wake of the me2 movement
women are calling them unfair silencers
that sweep sexual misconduct claims
under the rug why now because I think
this is the latest phase in the
revolution we've made so much progress
over the last three years we want to
speak for ourselves we had a voice for a
very long time gretchen carlson and
julie were against these signed
settlement agreements barring them from
speaking publicly about alleged sexual
harassment at Fox News the way in which
we continue to subjugate women and keep
them down is through NDA's and silencing
them it's really a harasser s best
friend but now they say they're tired of
being silent I want to do it for the
thousands of women in our country who
maybe don't have the national platform
to speak out Carlson was the first of
numerous women who filed lawsuits
against Fox News and its then president
Roger Ailes for claims of sexual
harassment and discrimination some would
say a company didn't make you sign a
settlement what do you say to that I say
that that's the way that we have decided
as a culture to resolve sexual
harassment cases and it's wrong in a
lawsuit Carlson alleged al sabotaged her
career because she refused his sexual
advances court documents alleged Carlson
was terminated from the network in 2016
you know Indiana has been in the news a
lot legally over the past couple days
Rogan ski said in her lawsuit Ailes and
Fox News denied her a regular spot
hosting a show called the five at
she refused to have a sexual
relationship with the former network
chief you all were awarded money
compensated financially you can't even
say you can't even say that no someone
has to speak up someone has to get mad
they're also not allowed to discuss the
way they're being portrayed in recent
movies you're sexy but you're too much
work
Carlson is being played by Nicole Kidman
in the movie bombshell
which tells the story about the takedown
of Ailes we would have liked to have
been able to tell our sides of the story
so that's strange and frustrating CBS
News legal analyst Ricky Clemens if Fox
is not going to release these women from
their NDA's are they going to go public
anyway well if they do they know what
the consequences are and they are big in
terms of dollars what's the consequence
if you did speak out I don't know the
answer to that but I don't want to find
out the onus shouldn't be on us to try
to find out the onus should be on the
companies to release us this is not an
issue that's only emblematic of one
industry or one political persuasion
it's emblematic of an entire culture in
a society that tells women that they
need to keep quiet and that has to end
Fox had no comment about releasing
people from NDA agreements many
companies including CBS have used
non-disclosure agreements and settling
claims according to CBS and previously
released people from confidentiality
provisions in order to allow them to
speak with investigators so you know
gretchen carlson as you all know is also
pushing legislation that would end
forced arbitration she's working with
senators Lindsey Graham and Kirsten
Gillibrand so it's not just the NDA it's
it's the policy changes that will make
it easier for women and men in some
cases to come forward well companies
always say they want the culture to
change that they want everybody to feel
safe and appreciated in the working
involved working environment then you
have to let them speak the truth and let
them tell their stories if they want
change one of the things I love that
Gretchen said during that interview is
if we're really going to solve this
problem it's also about lifting up our
boy she has a 14 year old son and I
think a lot of times men some you know
are left out of the conversation in a
way of
how this has changed your thoughts and
how you operate and how we are raising
our kids especially especially those two
very important point I think we'll hear
more from her
Jericka thank you very much